gut
jetzt wo wir uns alle hören
heiße ich
virtuell unsere Zuschauer willkommen
wir freuen uns dass wir die Gelegenheit
haben heute diesen Vortrag zu halten ist
und beide wie immer ein bisschen
aufgeregt
aber das werden wir schon schaukeln wie
sonst auch
also es geht heute darum was ist
eigentlich die Wikipedia und hat dem
Gesichtspunkt der Ethik der Herr Nöller
war so freundlich und hatte uns schon im
Vorfeld einige Fragen geschickt an dem
wir unseren Vortrag jetzt orientiert
haben
bei der Wikipedia verhält es sich so
dass wir uns alle duzen es werden wir
jetzt für den Vortrag auch machen
wir werden während des Vortrages keine
Zeit haben und in den Chat zu gucken
also alle Fragen bitte merken notieren
die könnt ihr dann hinterher loswerden
und was vielleicht auch noch wichtig ist
vorab zu sagen
wir sind keine Mitarbeiterinnen der
Wikipedia sondern machen das
ehrenamtlich in unser Freizeit als Hobby
so wie alle anderen Autorinnen
gut das war es vorweg hete dann
dann drücken
also erst einmal was zu unserer Person
mein Name ah du hast mir als erstes
gemacht
mein Name ist domenica Bolz weil
Wikipedia heiße ich Domenico bin seit
knapp 11 Jahren jetzt aktiv dabei
manchmal mit größeren Pausen aber jetzt
schon lange keine Pause mehr gemacht
wenn ich mal über ein Wochenende ohne
Laptop verreise fühle ich mich gleich
ein bisschen
ich schreibe gerne neue Artikel zu ganz
unterschiedlichen Themen
viel über Museen und Kunst aber auch
ganz absurde Sachen jetzt habe ich etwas
über ein mittelalterlichen quild
geschrieben
über eine Lyrikerin und aktuell über ein
Kunstfestival für zeitgenössische Japan
also ich fange mal alles auf was mir so
an Themen
entgegen fliegt und mich irgendwie
fasziniert dann gucke ich gleich nach ob
es dazu ein Artikel gibt und mit Glück
nicht
ich bin außerdem Mentoren für Wikipedia
Einsteigerinnen
das heißt wenn ein Einsteiger
zwar mitmachen möchte sich aber nicht
ganz zurechtfindet kann er sich einen
Mentor suchen und wir begleiten die
Person dann schriftlich durch die ersten
Schritte und helfen wie man einen
Artikel aufbaut oder wie die
Kommunikation auf der Wikipedia läuft
worauf man achten sollte wo die Fallen
sind oder eben ein paar Tipps und Tricks
die wir vermitteln
es läuft so drei viertel Jahr bis ein
Jahr je nachdem wie viel Bedarf da ist
ich schreibe gerne Artikel für den
Kasten schon gewusst der ist auf der
Startseite von der Wikipedia da gibt es
alle ein bis zwei Tage ein paar neue
Artikel oft mit ein bisschen skurrilen
Themen
und wenn ich einen Artikel fertig habe
schaue ich ob ich den dort unterbringen
kann
und ich unternehme gerne reisen mit
Vicky Glam das ist eine
Veranstaltungsreihe die jetzt im Zuge
der Pandemie etwas zurückgeschraubt
wurde nun aber wieder auflebt da lädt
die Wiki Media aus Berlin uns ein bei
verschiedenen zu verschiedenen
kulturellen Einrichtungen zu fahren
und dort bekommen wir dann spezielle
Führung und Schreiben im Laufe des
Ausflugs eben Artikel die mit der
Einrichtung zusammenhängen das macht
viel Spaß und man lernt
Wikipedianer aus anderen Städten kennen
ich übergebe an die Katrin
ja
ich hoffe ich bin noch zu hören
wunderbar also mein Name ist Katrin
Herbig im wirklichen Leben in der
Wikipedia habe ich den Nutzernamen Kette
17 das ist auch ganz wichtig für
Wikipedianer innen sich ein möglichst
absurden
Benutzernamen zuzulegen das ist dann
irgendwie Grottenolm 789 oder so oder
Kälte 17 ich bin seit fünf Jahren in der
Wikipedia aktiv also angemeldet habe ich
mich 2017 deswegen auch der Name Kälte
17 das ist nicht mein Geburtsjahr wie
jemand mal meinte
genau und ich habe aber ernsthaft erst
2018 und zwar Ende 2018 angefangen weil
ich am Anfang die Wikipedia echt so ein
bisschen unwirtlich fand und die ist ja
auch nicht so schön gestaltet ich bin
Grafikdesignerin das fand ich alles so
geil
und das ist glaube ich auch nicht
untypisch dass Leute sich anmelden und
dann erstmal gar nicht so viel Lust
haben und dann gibt es irgendeinen
auslösendes Moment für mich war das das
Thema das eben Frauen nicht so besonders
also das Frauen unterdurchschnittlich
vertreten sind sowohl was die Artikel
als auch die Autorenschaft betrifft und
dann habe ich mir gedacht na ja
na ja dann dann fange ich da halt mal an
Quell und seitdem habe ich nicht mehr
aufgehört weil das mich so begeistert
das Projekt
was ich mache ist dass ich gerne
bestehende Artikel verbessere korrigiere
ausbaue weil das werdet ihr ja
wahrscheinlich selber auch schon bemerkt
haben manche Artikel sind gar nicht so
gut und da gibt es immer sehr viel zu
tun
ich schreibe auch gerne neue Artikel in
den unterschiedlichsten Bereichen also
mein man Kerngebiet ist eigentlich diese
das Frauenthema und die Kultur aber wenn
ich zum Beispiel einen Computerprogramm
sehe was ich da gerade lernen muss für
die Arbeit und was noch keinen eigenen
Artikel hat dann schreibe ich da auch
einen Artikel dazu oder demnächst werde
ich über einen Gesellschaftsspiel einen
Artikel schreiben oder
also was einem so zwischen die Finger
kommt also wenn man irgendwas wo liest
und man denkt sich das ist aber
interessant und da gibt's noch keinen
Artikel
genau und ich trage gerne mit Fotos zu
Artikeln bei ich gehe raus und
fotografiere und stelle dann diese Fotos
in die Artikel und ich mag Wiki data das
ist so eine Datenbank für strukturierte
Daten unter freie Lizenz da werdet ihr
jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen hey was Wiki
was aber im Laufe des Vortrags kommen
wir noch öfters darauf zu sprechen und
dieses Foto was ihr da links von mir
seht da bin ich mit der sogenannten Wiki
Eule zu sehen
diese Wiki Eule habe ich mit anderen
zusammen für einen gemeinsames Projekt
bekommen 2021 auf der Wiki con
und außerhalb der Wikipedia kennt diese
Eulen kein Mensch innerhalb der
Wikipedia sind die total wichtig das ist
sowas wie die wie wie unsere
Oskar-Verleihung und das ist irgendwie
ein Riesending sowas zu kriegen und
deswegen schaue ich da auch so mega
glücklich aus der Wäsche
genau ich glaube dann bin ich jetzt
durch
hinzufügen dass du die Eule vollkommen
zurecht bekommen hast geht da hat
nämlich in der harten pandemiezeit die
Fahne oben gehalten und unseren Münchner
community
und dann sage ich auch noch kurz was die
in meinem Foto nein ich gucke nicht
immer so da war ich in einem Museum und
man durfte diese Trachtenhüte aufsetzen
und das fand ich sehr lustig deshalb
habe ich das
okay weiter geht's
das war die Animation
also ich fange mal an mit ein paar
übergreifenden Informationen was ist die
Wikipedia
wikipedia ist eine Enzyklopädie die so
viel Wissen wie möglich allgemein
verständlich
für alle kostenfrei und werbefrei
zugänglich machen möchte
jetzt wird der ein oder andere von euch
vielleicht sagen so ganz werbefrei ist
das ja nicht da sind immer so Banner wo
man spenden soll das geht aber alles
sozusagen in die eigene Kasse es ist
keine Werbung die von außen geschaltet
wird
Wikipedia gibt es 196 Ländern der Welt
und die Artikel sind pro Land oder viel
mehr pro Sprachgruppe unter Umständen
unterschiedlich es wird nicht gerne
gesehen dass man zum Beispiel ein
Artikel aus der englischsprachigen
Wikipedia einfach übersetzt und in die
deutsche Wikipedia stellt dieses
importieren ist möglich
aber schöner ist es wenn man seinen
eigenen Artikel baut oder auf dem was
eine andere Sprache bietet aufbaut
das führt dann auch dazu
ich habe zum Beispiel einmal einen
Artikel geschrieben über den Panzerzug
von Leo Trotzki
und hatte mir dazu etwas Hefe geholt von
einem Wikipedianer aus Russland der mir
ein paar
russische Sachen übersetzt hat die ich
mit Google nicht hatte übersetzen können
und als der Artikel dann irgendwann
fertig war hat er mir geschrieben ja
guck mal jetzt ist der deutsche Artikel
über den russischen Leo trotz wie viel
besser als unser da müssen wir noch mal
nachlegen
also jede Sprache hat ihre eigenen
Version
es gibt über 2 Millionen
740.000 oder wie immer man diese riesige
Zahl aussprechen mag Artikel im
deutschen Sprachraum
ein Artikel wohlgemerkt braucht minimal
drei Sätze dann ist es ein sogenannter
Stump wir versuchen das zu vermeiden
aber es trifft man immer wieder das ist
dann was verkehrte den Artikel
auszubauen und zu verbessern
es kann nicht alles zu einem Artikel
gemacht werden dazu gibt es diese
sogenannten Relevanz Kriterien das heißt
man kann prüfen ist dieser Künstler
relevant für die Wikipedia ist das Buch
relevant da gibt es zu allen möglichen
Stichpunkten gewisse Rahmen Kriterien an
dem man sich orientieren kann
eine Auszeichnung für Artikel ist das
Prädikat lesenswert oder exzellent
das kennt außerhalb der Wikipedia auch
kaum jemand dann hat der Artikel oben so
ganz kleines Zeichen und sagt hey dieser
Artikel ist lesenswert das lohnt sich da
mal reinzuschauen
0,1 Prozent der deutschen Bevölkerung
sind Autoren
wobei dieser Zahl sehr schwierig
zu generieren ist was genau ist ein
Autor ich glaube in dieser Zahl ist
zugrunde gelegt dass man fünf
Bearbeitungen sogenannte Edits im Monat
macht
allerdings sind die
richtigen Autoren die
hardcore-autoren jeden Tag so ein bis
zwei Stunden in der Wikipedia und da
kommt dann wesentlich mehr zusammen
Käthe schüttelt den Kopf ganz gleich
finde das nur bedenklich dass wir so
viel Zeit in der Wikipedia verbringen
und weiß nicht ob wir das den jungen
Menschen wirklich aufs Brot schmieren
wollen aber das haben wir ja schon getan
was Wikipedia nicht ist
es ist keine Werbeplattform
es gibt immer wieder
Firmen oder Menschen die sich gerne in
der Wikipedia haben und lesen möchten
und dann sehr gefällige Artikel zu sich
selber reinschreiben
diese Artikel bekommenden entweder
gleich einen Löschantrag das heißt es
wird diskutiert ob diese Artikel
überhaupt Bestand hat ob er relevant ist
und ob er drin bleiben soll oder
gelöscht werden sollte
oder es gibt auch die
neutralitätsbausteine die markieren
solche Artikel und sagen hey das ist
aber nicht sehr neutral formuliert das
könnte man doch vielleicht noch ein
bisschen von verschiedenen Perspektiven
aufbereiten so etwas bearbeite ich sehr
gerne zum Beispiel
die Wikipedia ist auch kein Fachlexikon
so als Zielgruppe im Hinterkopf haben
wir 17-Jährige schüler:innen die sollten
das verstehen es ist kein
Fachbegriffe sollten verständlich
erklärt werden nicht so lange Schächte
Sätze schreiben und so weiter
und es ist auch kein Reiseführer
Öffnungszeiten oder ähnliches am grandyx
verloren das wäre auch viel zu aufwendig
um die Daten aktuell zu halten dafür
gibt es das Schwesterprojekt von der
Wikipedia das heißt wikiwoyage da kann
man mal reinschauen wenn man sich auf
einen Urlaub vorbereitet da sind solche
Informationen dann richtig aufgehoben
und bitte weiter
okay
ja ich erzähle euch jetzt ein bisschen
was zur Geschichte von Wikipedia wie hat
sich das denn eigentlich entwickelt es
war einmal um die Jahrtausendwende da
gab es so verschiedene Bestrebungen eine
Online-Enzyklopädie im damals noch recht
neuen Internet auf die Beine zu stellen
das haben verschiedene Unternehmungen
Unternehmen oder Menschen versucht
aufzustellen unter anderem die
Internetunternehmer Jimmy ways und Larry
Sänger
die haben ein Projekt namens new Pedia
erstmal gegründet und das sollte
eigentlich so funktionieren dass ich
Autoren und vermutlich auch Autorinnen
dort bewerben konnten und dann sollten
sie da was schreiben und dann sollte das
sollte das in einem Tier Review
Verfahren
sehr kompliziert und sehr viel stufig
und sehr genau
bearbeitet werden und am Schluss sollte
dann ein super toll bearbeiteter Text
online stehen
das hat aber irgendwie niemanden so
richtig interessiert und das hat
überhaupt nicht an Fahrt aufgenommen und
hat es so ein bisschen so vor sich
hingedunkelt und dann haben die beiden
Jimmy Wells und Larry Sänger sind dann
auf so eine spaßidee gekommen nämlich
gab es da auch relativ neu
eine eine Software die die heißt Wiki
und dieses Wort Wiki kommt aus dem
hawaiianischen und heißt einfach schnell
ähm und das ist eine Kollaboration
kollaborative Software ein
kollaboratives Content Managementsystem
mit dem Schwerpunkt darauf dass von
verschiedenen Stellen über den Browser
das System bearbeitet werden kann
und und möglichst unkompliziert der
Schwerpunkt liegt überhaupt nicht
aufgestaltung
sondern eher auf den kollerativen
Zugriff und damit haben die eben diese
Wikipedia aufgebaut als irgendwie so
Spaß Dings
und dieses Spaß Dings hat dann total
viel Zulauf bekommen und zwar deswegen
weil das so offen war das fanden die
Leute toll dass sie da einfach was
reinschreiben können und
dann hat das diese ursprüngliche new
Pedia innerhalb von kürzester Zeit
abgelöst und wurde immer erfolgreicher
und 2003 hatte das ehemalige Spaßprojekt
den Jupiter abgelöst
ebenfalls 2001 wenn ich mich nicht
täusche im März 2001 ist dann auch
gleich die deutschsprachige Wikipedia
gegründet worden und auch weitere also
anderssprachige Wikipedia
habe ich was vergessen nee genau und
dann ging das dann ging das so flott
weiter 2004 wurde die Bilddatenbank wie
ich gekommens gegründet die ihr
vielleicht auch kennt vielleicht aber
auch nicht also das Wiki Commons hat den
Vorteil dass dass die Bilder zentral
gespeichert werden und wenn ich da
einmal ein Bild hochgeladen habe dann
kann ich das in der in der deutschen in
der englischsprachigen in der persischen
in der italienischen in der polnischen
und so weiter Wikipedia einbauen ehrlich
gesagt das ist meine meine meine größte
Freude Bilder in Wikipedia einzubauen
deren Schriftsysteme ich gar nicht kenne
genau und ähm bis 2007 wurden das immer
mehr Beiträge und immer mehr Autorinnen
die da Lust hatten mitzumachen und
Wikipedia war der heiße Scheiß sozusagen
seid ihr geht das Wachstum ein bisschen
zurück also es ist immer noch so eine so
auf so ein Plateau und hat aber so ein
leichten
leichte Tendenz nach unten andere würden
sagen wieso
Benutzer bzw
Mitarbeitenden Zahlen bleiben gleich
aber ich würde sagen es hat schon wenn
man eine Kugel drauflegen würde würde
sie eher nach unten rollen
genau und damit die wachsende
artikelflut die ist aber trotzdem gibt
also es wäre trotzdem täglich mehr
Artikel damit die
besser aktualisiert werden kann wurde
2012 die Datenbank Wiki data für die
strukturierte Daten gegründet damit z.B
kann man spannende Sachen wie Infokästen
automatisch befüllen die gibt man dann
einfach
das da gibt man die Informationen einmal
ein und ähm dann verteilt sich das über
dieser sämtliche Wikipedia wo dieser
Infokasten installiert worden ist
naja Details später also jedenfalls ist
die Tat data großartig und was ganz
wichtig ist Wikipedia ist die einzige
der dieser großen Internetplattformen
die ja alle so in der Zeit entstanden
behaupte ich jetzt mal
die nicht in der Hand eines Konzerns ist
oder eines Milliardärs oder einer
Milliardärin sondern die von den
BenutzerInnen selbst organisiert wird
ja und diese Infos habe ich mir nicht
ausgedacht sondern größtenteils aus dem
Wikipedia-Artikel zu Wikipedia
rausgelesen bzw ist das mündliche
Überlieferung von bekannten
genau damit wäre die kleine
geschichtseinheit zu Ende und ich gebe
weiter an die Dominika
ja wir haben es schon eine Menge über
Wikipedia gehört was ist die
Besonderheit daran also zum einen ist es
frei zugänglich man muss sich nicht
registrieren man muss sich nicht mal
anmelden jeder kann einfach mitmachen
und jeder kann dabei das Einbringen was
ihn interessiert viele denken bei
Wikipedia nur an das Schreiben von
Artikeln aber es sind eben auch Fotos
wie Katrin schon gesagt hat das
Überprüfen vom bestehenden Artikeln oder
von Daten die Qualitätssicherung gerade
von neueren Artikeln von Benutzern die
das noch nicht so oft gemacht haben
das wird auch alles von Ehrenamtlichen
betreut dann kann man sich mit
Datenbanken einbringen mit
Programmierung als Mentoren man kann
Kurse anbieten man kann Sachen
aktualisieren Diagramme erstellen oder
Karten man kann
Recherchearbeit leisten für andere
in Bibliotheken Sachen nachschauen wo
diejenigen aufgrund ihres Standortes
nicht rankommen
man kann sich in Projekten engagieren
wie zum Beispiel die Reisen die ich
eingangs erwähnt habe das wirklich oder
in den lokalen räumen da gibt es einige
in Deutschland wie wir auch in München
haben dazu erzählen wir nachher noch was
man kann Vorträge halten so wie diesen
also es ist eine unglaubliche Bandbreite
wie man sich einbringen kann auch von
der Zeit her
ist das ein Hobby wo man sich wirklich
das nach seinem Alltag richten kann wenn
man gerade mal Urlaub hat kann man jeden
Tag fünf Stunden Wikipedia machen
tut es vielleicht auch 5 Minuten die
Woche
eine weitere Besonderheit ist die
Kommunikation
das heißt dadurch dass die Wikipedia ja
nur von Ehrenamtlichen
gesteuert wird wird alles ausdiskutiert
das ist eine hohe Kontrolle Instanz weil
viele Leute auf ein Thema schauen immer
die die sich gerade angesprochen fühlen
die es interessiert
das ist gelebte Demokratie sozusagen nur
der der wählen geht nur der damit
diskutiert kann dann auch was
entscheiden und da wird diskutiert ob
ein Thema überhaupt geeignet ist wie der
Titel klingen sollte ob der vielleicht
ob es ein besseren Titel gibt oder ob
man Artikel gelöscht werden soll
ich bin neulich über eine Diskussion
gestoßen was ist ein ganzer Satz da wird
denn die Grammatik einmal ganz neu
bewertet man kann diskutieren ob die
Quellen zu einem Artikel seriös genug
sind oder ob ein gewisser Benutzer
vielleicht gesperrt werden sollte weil
der lauter Unfug treibt
es wird überlegt wer wird Admin von
denen Benutzern das sind Benutzer die
ein bisschen mehr Rechte haben der wird
Mentor
was ist der Artikel des Tages und so
weiter alles wird diskutiert
wer keine Lust zum Lesen hat ist ein
bisschen schlecht dran
das klingt jetzt aber so als würden wir
viel Zeit auf Diskussion
verschwenden aber man muss nur so viel
diskutieren wie man selber Lust hat und
sich einbringen möchte man kann sich
auch davon ziemlich fernhalten jeder
Artikel hat übrigens eine
Diskussionsseite was man als normaler
Leser nicht unbedingt
wahrnimmt das über dem Artikel so eine
reiterleiste da steht auch Diskussion
und jeder der ein angemeldetes
Benutzerkonto hat hat auch eine eigene
Diskussionsseite wo man ihn Nachrichten
schicken kann Fragen stellen kann
danke schön Katrin
jo
die nächste Frage war wie kann Wikipedia
zur Verbreitung von Wissen oder gar
Bildung beitragen
ja also zum einen ist es ja so dass in
der Wikipedia das Wissen vollkommen frei
also kostenlos ohne
Zugangsbeschränkungen und unterfreien
Lizenzen zur Verfügung gestellt wird und
damit können rein theoretisch alle
jederzeit sich über fast alles
informieren oder wenn Sie das Gefühl
haben dass ihnen was fehlt können Sie da
auch was ergänzen
die Informationen aus den Wikipedia also
Wiki Projekten Wikipedia Wikipedia Wiki
comments Wiki data Viki sowas und so
weiter können jederzeit für eigene
Zwecke verwendet werden also die Quellen
kann man sich abgreifen die Bilder kann
man für eigene Zwecke verwenden auch für
kommerzielle Zwecken Zwecke man kann
Suchabfragen machen also in der schon
oft erwähnten
strukturierten Datenbank
machen auf relativ einfache Art und
Weise und kann sie für meine Forschung
verwenden
und wir laden dazu ein oder die
Wikipedia lädt dazu ein das freie Wissen
zu verbessern zu vermehren und zu teilen
und dadurch wird es ja theoretisch immer
mehr und wird verbreitet
und man kann sich damit bilden
die Wikipedia hat
sehr hohe Zugriffszahlen und sie ranked
bei Google ganz oben wenn ich irgendwas
suche dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
sehr hoch dass einer der ersten fünf
Treffer die Wikipedia ist möglicherweise
sogar noch weiter oben
und sie hat eben aufgrund der Qualität
die erstaunlicherweise bei diesen ganzen
basisdemokratischen Raum diskutiere
entsteht sie hat einfach nicht den
schlechtesten Ruf das ist wirklich
erstaunlich dass so ein Projekt dass das
wirklich im großen und ganzen so eine
gute Qualität fabriziert
[Musik]
ich möchte aber auch die Gefahr
ansprechen
die dadurch
entsteht dass Leute einfach aus der
Wikipedia abschreiben wenn man mal für
eigene Artikel recherchiert oder wenn
man zum Beispiel Artikel verbessern
möchte und sich denkt so komisch da
steht gar keine Quelle zu diesem Absatz
ich guck mal ob ich was finde und dann
stellt man fest dass überall diese
Absatz
verwendet wird in anderen
Artikeln oder arbeiten und dann denkt
man sich auch nicht aber das ist der
einzige das ist der einzige nicht
belegte Absatz in dem ganzen Artikel und
den finde ich jetzt hier 25 mal also
sowas passiert durchaus jetzt nicht so
oft aber es ist passiert und deswegen
sitzen oft Topic zu diesem Zeit aber es
lohnt sich immer die Quellen also wenn
wenn ihr irgendwie Wikipedia verwendet
für eure Arbeiten nutzt die Quellen die
da immer angegeben sind im Artikel
selber kann sich schon mal ein
Fehlerchen einschleichen
genau aber so kann Wikipedia zur
Verbreitung von Wissen oder Bildung
beitragen es ist komplett frei und man
kann es wie eine Pusteblume durch die
Gegend stauben
domenica dein Part ja
ich weiß nicht wie kleine es hört mein
Hund ist gerade begeistert mit seinem
Spielzeug zugange
mein Mann versucht ihn ein bisschen weg
zu locken okay danke
also ja das Quietschen war natürlich
beabsichtig denn hier das Bild mit
Quietscheentchen das reiht sich ein wie
stellt die Wikipedia die Objektivität
sicher
ganz einfach wie wir schon die ganze
Zeit erzählt haben eben durch die vielen
Mitwirkenden und durch die
Vielseitigkeit an mit
jeder Mensch ist anders jeder Mensch
weiß was anderes und interessiert sich
für etwas anderes wenn dann alle so ein
bisschen dran mit Rum wischen
entsteht ein objektives Bild eines
Themen im Optimalfall
es ist ein Muss dass man in einen
Artikel Quellen angeben muss woher man
diese Informationen hat
die Wikipedia verwendet keine
Primärquellen also es geht nicht darum
jetzt dort seine eigenen Forschungen zu
veröffentlichen sondern irgendwo
abzulesen was haben denn die Leute dazu
geforscht und dann wenn es möglich ist
auch verschiedene Sichtweisen davon
darzustellen und immer anzugeben woher
habe ich diese Information
es gibt eine Funktion die heißt
beobachten da kann ich Artikel
beobachten die ich zum Beispiel
geschrieben habe dann habe ich sie in
der Wikipedia veröffentlicht und möchte
aber im Auge behalten was passiert dann
mit diesem Artikel wer macht denn da
Änderung und was Veränderung sind das
sinnvolle Änderungen in meinen Augen
oder sollte ich mir das mit der Person
diskutieren ob wir das vielleicht anders
machen wollen dafür gibt's die
beobachten Funktion so dass man von
einem Thema über das man schon
geschrieben hat dass man da immer dran
bleiben kann
außerdem bei neuen benutzer:innen gibt
es das sogenannte sichten
jeder der eine gewisse Anzahl an der
arbeitungen durchgeführt hat kann sich
als Sichter bei der Wikipedia anmelden
und wenn dann ein neuer Nutzer eine
Änderung macht
geht die erstmal sozusagen in einem
geschützten Raum online da können die
sich da denn drauf schauen und sagen
okay das ist eine sinnvolle Änderung das
Richten Haken dran und damit wird es
veröffentlicht
damit wird zum einen etwas Schindluder
in Bann gehalten zum Beispiel
ich finde die jakob-schweitzer-schule
doof weil gerade ein Schüler eben auf
die Jakob Schweizer Schule geht das
können wir dann wieder rausschmeißen
oder aber Leute die sich wirklich noch
nicht so gut auskennen haben etwas
hinzugefügt was nicht ganz normal
korrekt ist dann kann man das schnell
erklären und die Sache danach online
stellen
die Objektivität wird auch gesichert
dadurch dass einfach unglaublich viele
Leute lesen
und
sich gegebenenfalls melden oder selber
Veränderung vornehmen neue Daten
einfügen neue Informationen dazu tun
deshalb ist ein Artikel auch nie fertig
es wird immer weiter dran rum gebastelt
von allen möglichen Seiten
[Musik]
es gibt einige Artikel in denen das
Basteln temporär untersagt ist
wenn dazu viel los ist oder wenn viel
haben um ein Thema gemacht wird zum
Beispiel auch Angela Merkel so ein ganz
prominenter Artikel wenn jeder meint er
müsste jetzt was dazu schreiben oder
findet die Frau doof und das muss ja
jetzt rein er wird der Artikel temporär
gesperrt für neue Veränderung
denn wieder der neutralitätsbaustein den
ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe wenn man
den Eindruck hat man liest etwas was
nicht objektiv ist kann man diesen
Artikel markieren als nicht objektiv
und wieder die Diskussionsseiten wenn
ich merke hey das scheint mir nicht so
richtig zu sein kann ich bei dem Artikel
auf der Diskussionsseite an dem
entsprechenden Kommentar reinsetzen und
mal die anderen Leute fragen was sie
denn davon halten
mit diesen ganzen Werkzeugen versuchen
wir es möglichst objektiv zu halten und
Käthe möchte weitermachen bitte schön
ja mir ist nämlich gerade aufgefallen
dass wir glaube ich das Timing total
gereißen gerade nein
wunderbar was kommen noch wir sind in
der Mitte
die Zuhörenden holt euch ein Käsebrot
oder Nein bleibt am Bildschirm
es bleibt spannend genau denn die
wichtige Frage wie kann Wikipedia Fake
News vermeiden
Wikipedia hat ja
ist auch die erste und manchmal leider
oft die einzige Informationsquelle die
Leute befragen zu irgendwas
der ist eigentlich an Angela Merkel
was ist eigentlich bei und Tech und
deswegen hat Wikipedia auch irgendwie so
eine ziemliche Verantwortung
zu schauen dass das Fake News sich da
nicht durchsetzen
und durch die schon erwähnten hohen
Zugriffszahlen und durch das Gute
Ranking bei Google ist es so dass was da
steht in der Wikipedia wirklich viele
lesen und eben es ist halt auch das
einzige was sie lesen
aber gute Nachricht zumindest bei den
großen Themen schreiben so viele mit
dass eigentlich in der Regel die
Qualität gesichert ist
und da wird dann ganz schön gestritten
und diskutiert im Hintergrund aber es
nutzt der Qualität in eben diesen
allermeisten Fällen
es herrscht eine Belegpflicht ich glaube
die herrscht seit 2008 das heißt man
kann in der Regel immer sehen woher
welche Infos kommen wenn da irgendein
Absatz steht wo ich mit denke sondern er
kann ja nicht sein dann schaue ich
welcher Beleg dem zugeordnet ist und da
kann ich das nachprüfen ich kann aber
auch wenn da was drin steht und das ist
zum Beispiel nicht belegt dann kann ich
diese Quelle jederzeit in Frage stellen
jeder kann das jede und jeder kann das
ähm und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt
also ich möchte da jetzt wirklich nicht
als Autorin mitmachen das ist mir
irgendwie zu zu heikel dann kann man das
auf die Diskussionsseite schreiben also
rein theoretisch und kann sagen hey in
dem Absatz der Absatz ist doch gar nicht
belegt ich glaube das nicht und dann
kann man halt darauf hoffen dass die
anderen sich darum kümmern
es gibt immer die Möglichkeit Artikel
zeitweise zu sperren wenn Leute
gefährlichen mist da reinschreiben dann
kann das eben passieren dass dass die so
eine zeitweise Sperrung bekomme ich
glaube domenica hatte das schon erwähnt
genau und im Idealfall ist es so dass
durch die Diskussion
die Neutralität die wir ja erreichen
möchten entsteht und auch die sichere
Faktenlage weil einfach so viele Leute
dann immer rum kritisieren und rum
meckern bis es halt dann irgendwann
wirklich
klar ist und nicht also
ja das ist stimmt
so viel zu den Fake News
dominik hat sich das Prinzip der
Anonymität oder Wikipedia bewährt den
möchte ich vorausschicken dass die
Anonymität kein Muss ist
man kann auch als User seinen normalen
Namen als User Namen wählen oder auf
seiner eigenen persönlichen
Benutzerseite schreiben mein Username
ist Sockenpuppe 312 aber im echten Leben
heiße ich Hans Hirsch also man kann
entscheiden wie anonym man in der
Wikipedia auftreten möchte um
vollständig anonym zu bleiben legt man
gar kein Konto an dann wird eine
IP-Adresse als Absender angezeigt das
hat in Deutschland allerdings ein
bisschen ein schlechteren Ruf weil man
nie genau weiß wer dahinter
einmal davon ausgeht die Leute haben
vielleicht einen Grund
sich nicht richtig endlich zu machen
für repressive Länder ist die Anonymität
und im Pseudonym natürlich Gold wert
wenn man sich dort neutral austauschen
kann und vielleicht über nicht ganz so
neutrale politische Systeme
austauschen kann
in der Diskussion
wird die Anonymität natürlich immer
Gefahr dass die Leute unfreundlich
werden so im Internet da schreibt man
denn schnell mal irgendwas hin was man
jemanden ins Gesicht nicht sagen würde
der raue Ton ist auch etwas was einigen
Wikipedia an den Einstieg erschwert
deshalb setzen wir uns sehr dafür ein
dass man freundlich aufgenommen wird und
man auch freundlich miteinander reden
kann dass man dem anderen immer
das Beste unterstellt auch wenn es
vielleicht nicht ganz so formuliert ist
dazu gibt es auch eine Bewegung die
heißt
das Gute Anonymität ist das ist
dass man ohne große Hürden Artikel
schreiben kann in der richtigen Welt
könnte zum Beispiel nur ein studierter
Facharzt jetzt ein Artikel zum
medizinischen Thema schreiben in der
Wikipedia könnte auch ich als Laien
diesen Artikel schreiben wenn ich ihn
gut recherchiere da geht es denn nur um
die Qualität und nicht um meine
beruflichen Werdegang
danke
so
die Frage kam auf wie kann Wikipedia zur
digitalen Aufklärung beitragen sowohl
regional als auch international
ja also wer sich mit der Wikipedia ein
bisschen beschäftigt lernt dass sich
Informationen auch jenseits der großen
Konzerne organisieren lassen das gehört
für mich zur digitalen Aufklärung dass
man merkt dass es eben auch also ich
muss jetzt nicht meine Daten
Facebook oder Google anvertrauen es gibt
auch das kleine gallische Dorf namens
Wikipedia so geht's also auch
und theoretisch können ja alle auf alle
Wikipedia-Artikel zugreifen das bedeutet
ja das heißt bis auf Länder in denen sie
gerade gesperrt ist
da gibt es allerdings Workouts wie zum
Beispiel VPN-Tunnel
wer bei der Wikipedia mitwirkt
lernt das dass man Informationen
hinterfragen muss das hat zum Beispiel
ich seit ich da mitmache bin ich viel
kritischer geworden und frag viel öfters
nach so stimmt denn das wer sagt denn
das
weil ins Internet kann man alles
mögliche reinschreiben aber ob es dann
stimmt
und
vielleicht wenn das einige von euch
eigenartig finden aber ich finde die
Wikipedia steht für eine
Diskussionskultur also im Guten wie im
Schlechten natürlich läuft bei der
Wikipedia eben durch diese
online-diskussionenskultur die die
Dominika schon beschrieben hat einiges
nicht so toll aber man lernt tatsächlich
sich durchzusetzen oder eben auch mal zu
sagen ich bleibe ich bleibe hier dran
weil wenn ich jetzt irgendwie nachgebe
dann dann kann ich mein Interesse nicht
verfolgen und dann dann gewinnen ja die
anderen
andererseits lernt man auch dass man
sagt so ich glaube die anderen haben
recht ich glaube hier muss ich nachgeben
und das ist wie also schon sagt gerade
in der heutigen Zeit glaube ich gar
nicht so schlecht dass das zu lernen
genau Dominika von von Gegenständen
nicht gleich persönlich angegriffen zu
fühlen genau
ja welchen Problem stellt sich die
Wikipedia im Moment besonders einmal wie
es Käthe eingangs schon gesagt hat dass
die Anzahl der autore:innen in
Deutschland
eher abnimmt es gibt Verhältnis wie
verhältnismäßig wenige Menschen die über
verhältnismäßig viele Themen schreiben
dass gefährdet dann die Neutralität
und unter diesen Autorin
Autorin sind die Autorinnen besonders
wenig die sind unter repräsentiert
ebenso wie denn die weiblichen Themen
oder die weibliche Betrachtungsweisen
das setze ich alles in Anführungszeichen
je mehr Sichtweisen man auf ein Thema
hat von je mehr Menschen desto neutraler
wird das Thema bearbeitet
deshalb wäre es schön mehr Frauen in der
Wikipedia begrüßen zu dürfen wir sind
hier in München ein haben wir relativ
viele Frauen im Team nämlich genau vier
die sich aktiv mit einbringen
und wir würden uns über neue
MitstreiterInnen besonders freuen
ich denke auch manchmal dass der
Umgangston
vielleicht ein bisschen freundlicher
wäre wären mehr Frauen dort muss aber
nicht sein
die Mitwirkenden bei der Wikipedia sind
generell recht homogen vom
Bildungsniveau her so die Akademiker und
die alten weißen Männer die jetzt in
Rente sind und dafür Zeit haben wie geht
es leider wirklich sehr viel
wir setzen uns dafür ein dass es etwas
gemischter wird
in manchen Regionen der Welt ist die
Wikipedia sowieso
unterrepräsentiert man guckt nach Afrika
oder nach China es kann an der
Infrastruktur liegen es kann am
politischen System liegen also in Europa
und USA sind wir da natürlich gut
aufgestellt
ein weiteres Problem ist das paid
editing das heißt Politiker oder Firmen
oder dergleichen mit Zahlen Autoren
damit sie in ein Artikel schreiben
ist ein ganz rotes Tuch unter dem
wikipedianerinnen
aber ich fürchte da sind wir noch am
Anfang der Fahnenstange da wird die
Zukunft noch einiges dazu bringen
und es gibt immer mehr Artikel und damit
auch immer mehr Artikel die gewartet
werden müssen wo es neue Infos gibt wo
veraltete Sachen drin stehen
das ist ein Berg der am wachsen ist
das wird uns auch in die Zukunft
begleiten
Stichwort Zukunft
wie sehen wir die Zukunft von Wikipedia
also sagen wir mal so wenn das gelingt
auf die Dauer genügend und auch
unterschiedliche Menschen dazu zu
motivieren nicht nur die Wikipedia zu
lesen sondern sich auch einzubringen und
ein bisschen mitzumachen dann glaube ich
ist die Zukunft gar nicht so schlecht
aber dass das wirklich wichtig dass das
die Wikipedia nicht mehr nur
wahrgenommen wird als eine Plattform für
pensionierte Studienräte sondern auch
dass man also nicht nur als Frau sich da
irgendwie angesprochen fühlt sondern
auch als als nicht weiß Brot und als
nicht aus den äh aus dem
Wohlstandsländern kommt
und da komme ich auch schon zum Punkt
zwei die mobile Bearbeitung das ist ja
im Moment ist es muss man das wirklich
wollen aber zum Beispiel in in Schwellen
oder
Entwicklungsländern gibt es halt pro ist
halt ein Rechner und den hat halt der
das Familienoberhaupt quasi für seine
Arbeit und die
mal üblicherweise ist es halt die
Ehefrau die sitzt halt in der Küche und
würde vielleicht auch gerne was was
machen hat aber halt das Handy und dann
ist es halt klar wer dann im also in
diesem Modellfall den Wikipedia-Artikel
schreibt
[Musik]
wir also genau das wäre eine tolle
Zukunft in der diese mobile Bearbeitung
gut geht aber gute Nachricht wir sind
dran also daran wird gearbeitet und
das wäre schön wenn die
Wikimedia-Projekte als als Ort auf
freies Wissen zuzugreifen und an ihm zu
arbeiten
weiterhin gesehen werden oder sich darin
bewähren
[Musik]
was auch eben auch in Arbeit ist ist die
wertschätzende online-diskussionskultur
also ich denke wenn wir das irgendwie
hinkriegen deinen Weg zu finden dass
Leute sich da wohlfühlen dann ist es
doch die Zukunft ganz ruhig und auf der
anderen Seite ist die Wikipedia wirklich
ein Ort an dem man sich mit anderen
austauscht mit anderen mit denen man
sonst nie in Kontakt kommen würde und
indem man auch lernt andere Meinungen
auszuhalten und seinen Mund aufzumachen
oder ihren und aufzumachen
für uns ist tatsächlich auch wichtig und
das wird
das wird es hoffentlich auch in der
Zukunft immer öfter geben dass man sich
nicht nur online austauscht dass man
sich in den sogenannten lokalen Räumen
trifft und kennenlernt und dann eben
sich denkt ach die Person schreibt zwar
immer so komisch aber eigentlich ist die
ganz nett und die meint es nicht so oder
irgendwie
der Mensch nervt mich jetzt aber
eigentlich finde ich den total nett und
da hat mir mal geholfen also bin ich
jetzt nicht sofort beleidigt oder so und
mai also wie im richtigen Leben wenn man
halt so Kontakte knüpft und und Bande
knüpft dann dann dann dann wie soll ich
sagen dann
ist das halt eben auch gut für die
Kommunikationskultur und Stichwort
lokaler Raum kleine werbeschleife noch
zum Abschied
wir das wie genug also die Domenico
domenica und ich sind im Wiki Muck aktiv
das ist der lokale Raum für München der
ist gleich hinter dem Sendlinger Tor in
der angertorstraße unter dieser E-Mail
Quatsch unter dieser URL wiki.org findet
ihr unsere ansprechend gestaltete
Termine Seite
wir haben jeden Mittwoch einen
sogenannten offenen Abend da kann man
einfach vorbeikommen ab 19 Uhr und
Fragen stellen zum Beispiel in diesem
Artikel zu meiner Oma ist ein Fehler
drin wie mache ich den raus oder so oder
ich habe angefangen und jetzt weiß ich
nicht weiter also angefangen mit
Wikipedia
genau hier sieht man so ein paar Leute
genau das war unser letzter
studentinnenkurs mit der LMU zusammen
und ab und zu gehen wir gemeinsam ins
Museum
hier sieht man die einzige Frau ist
hinter der Kamera
genau ja
und ich glaube damit sind wir am Ende
domenica nickt auch und wir kommen jetzt
endlich zum Fragenteil